[Music]
hi Eddie
hahaha
families what about their character
balances and defense hope you got to do
a webpage reminder it's something I
thought you guys can all benefit from
the for Ramadan starts now guys as we
know for an intention I mean sorry for a
good bead or any kind of deed good deed
to be accepted there's two factors that
have to be there the first factor is
that your intentions have to be liked so
intentions are correct so when you're
doing a good deed your intentions are
correct the second thing is that the
actions and the things you do follow the
Sunnah the way of the Prophet are over
from Omaha you send them now a lot of
the times intention to their we have no
doubt about the intention that we can't
really talk about somebody's heart and
its intentions however the actions and
the things that I've done doesn't follow
now this is a reminder to me first
well there's a lot of the times where
intentions are there and the actions
that reduce etc doesn't follow and
sometimes this happens out of necessity
sometimes for example when we're out
giving Dawa etc sometimes we need to
speak to normals and females yes that
are not crisp appropriately become
trying to see and obviously as a man you
should lower against and I've seen from
such things but sometimes out on the
city the scholars have said when doing
bower something's in public so you can
even to a female as long as our related
and once our is done you go about your
own way and there's many other factors
like I said before I'm not perfect we're
falling - yeah so but the main thing is
that the intention and actually should
be there now if I'm Prince Allah if I
see you know one famous song close to
Allah today that I just I'm so so close
coastal also planet Allah
I'm gonna pray Asia Seminole car to
extra for my love for Allah and His
Messenger
now the intentions are there no doubt
masha'Allah perfect good it's the actual
don't follow that will be rejected
from you it should be rejected that's
why you have some people in today's time
they do such a stinking yes you know we
love a lot love adventure etc but we're
not know if you love and follow his way
instead of doing things which you've
been hey you know what because I love
allen's messenger I'm gonna do this
search and act or this act or where that
rook follow the Sunnah now the biggest
problem that we have in today's time is
young Roberts like myself and one of
those young fellows brothers talking
about matters giving fatwa circulated
questions etc giving answer to this one
why I was thinking about this today and
had a sort of reminder on Twitter pearls
of knowledge and and it was of chefs ala
assault on may Allah have mercy on it
one of the biggest all amount of our
time their biggest biggest pull em off
our time now it makes you wonder and the
advisers of this when I'm going to share
with you guys we're gonna watch it right
now when I watch you right now and the
things that I said is trauma tell us so
true like online this is so true we've
got young brothers today yeah younger
than us going to direct I'm gonna be
direct these are the problems that used
to work with me Allah bless them I love
them too the sake of Allah they are good
prophets they are lovely bugs and they
love Allah religious they all love our
love religion I have no doubts about
that well why I can see to as well that
even when sometimes [ __ ] Hamburg Domino
these what has lost Allah say Allah and
even in one video where they're giving
like a ruling about our Neutral quote
sort of extremist is it claim that it's
we mix in big claims are being maybe and
I'm looking not thinking all young
brothers in their twenties sitting on a
table
one of the brothers may Allah bless them
is even praying and then we've got
another young brother they're seen these
are the people of desires and they don't
feel a lump occasionally from around I'm
looking at these brothers and I'm just
like wow poor young brothers talking
about matter gas got nothing to do with
them matters that today that seem sure
that we're talking about there is
scholars people of knowledge bargaining
watching it assessing it and look him to
understand why is it being done what's
the reason that it's being done is it
what's the fact that it hits remix it
better how can it be work they are the
ones that decide but today we've got
young brothers young brother sitting on
the table and talking about the affairs
of the Ummah with no knowledge I've said
it before guys I am nobody
that's why it was me I try my best I
don't have been some such spokes or
whatever I always go back to the scholar
we need to discuss such matters
I mean I wish I hate them I've got this
and different teachers I've got chef
Mohammed I've got different ages that I
go and my mentors and I talk to them I
don't talk of my own so college
informatics colors and this is the way
of the seller I can't come up here and
see brothers and sisters if a book talk
about and then get emotional emotions
like I said intentions might be there
but if your actions are not following
you're not following the Sunnah now
however we're going to do a video and I
not next ask the chef about me mixing
before I carry a list which is a
dissolution shadow falls on on in this
matter
and listen to him carefully may Allah
bless him going on rasul wailing
umbrella namie amuro namie okay Alison
Ilona Morrissey osnabrück leggies Tirana
agua de una segunda where are Margo
Funes Graham the hadith narrated a guru
Italy now of a young coconut cake hawala
LAN LAN world before learner Toronto
more he had a spare cot
and removal I applied the next night or
whenever it was
hey did I win oh Lord
nah no how does external hugging what
I'm sorry Canella cool you are happy if
they say how's the cuddly yes TV a kind
of liar when I hold on a portrayal of
you know my policy is useful for
yourself yeah this you saw for yourself
if we went to these orlimar be scholars
and we said to the letter group of
brothers giving how it's got given for
tower you're talking what you're doing
is you are guessing a matter which
nobody is confirming they look at the
three misses or you have come and thrown
an accusation that this is remixes which
it has been established and then you are
bringing court and versus taking them
out of content and making them you
basically reading into them and
connecting them to something else are
unrelated if we want a chef salad are
thousands and there's a group of
brothers young doing this well lie they
would wound against then another thing
and this could be me if this was me
being me doing it what we're trying to
see if office insisted is that you still
insist on a thousand saying these
methods are so big that if it was
brought that the time of the Sahaba at
the time of the Sahaba all of this
fibers will come together to understand
and derive a ruling and say you know
what we should do this about that today
we got four young brothers and many
other bodies in the comment section on
Instagram on Facebook
young brothers the reason I'm doing it
is because this kind of behavior
influences other young people to talk
about matters they are not knowledgeable
on we should not talk about matters that
we don't know we should stick to our
lane our limit we've got young robbers
coming and giving uncommon fiction this
is her on
bezel on giving rulings Sahaba imagine
all the Sahaba coming together that get
that alone we've got young brothers you
weak weak and messy me including all the
young lovers we can't be the top of the
Sahaba and there is matters I mean talk
when a scholar gives a fatwa the scholar
he's got knowledge
he's got hikmah he's got age on this
side hey Clark
obviously the wisdom but wisdom part of
age etc age he knows the affairs of the
people he knows the fate of the people
and he knows what's the right thing at
the right time to do a scholar doesn't
go back to just knowledge open the book
the book he says that I better ask
owners don't do this
scholars have to evaluate from the
affairs of the people the hikmaíah at
the time and the time it plays there 8
why did why did most of the profits get
revelation of 40 why why because they're
after age where they are seeing
everything and s mellowed down not young
zealous and hot-blooded
and this is the issue these people are
people of knowledge you might disagree
now with shaitan allah Darnell this'll
be you might disagree I disagree
something trajes and says me all a
blessing but in no way do you have a
right to commit a bad fatwa that person
is not a scholar or gorilla this is from
ignorance so brother see this is a
reminder for us all when we're doing
something we are emotional
don't let most again get in the way
don't talk about messiness over your
head leave this to the scholars I will
have no problem if these brothers came
together with a person of knowledge ace
scholar Asia and the chef came and said
for example I disagree with this table
that I have all shut my mouth because
why is the difference of opinion I would
all be quiet young brothers Allah this
is the son of the day of judgment young
brothers talking about matters over the
head the same goes with me I try my best
to stick to my lane my dream is Dharma
if I know something I'll convey if I
don't know if I don't know I'm sure that
I I don't know I don't know I might
respect everyone those who truly follow
the seller are those who say you know
what these are the Masters over my head
go back to the scholars and those kind
of bothers I'll respect and sisters so
guys are just a reminder for me hope you
guys benefit don't forget when we do an
action this Allah what does it may be
intention should be there and let the
actions follow that way focus on some
let's keep this in mind mission of our
ancestors now god bless you guys
assalamo a little whatever like that
shoo-shoo shoo-shoo shoo-shoo shoo-shoo
shoo-shoo hey give me one I'm funny
subscribe